so it's hard for you to want to show the
other person love because you're like
hey you're not showing me love why
should i show you love
that is something that is super common
i've totally experienced it myself
because i'm more likely to want to show
my partner love if he's showing me love
but who takes the first step who's the
first one to be like okay we're in a rut
right now we are not doing great
and we're not thriving because life is
crazy and it's hard to make our
relationship a priority
how do you decide who takes the first
step
and i think it really just comes down to
you if you are willing to take the first
step and show your partner love
[Music]
hey guys today i'm going to talk about
relationships and keeping the love alive
while raising your children it can be
easy to put your relationship with your
partner on the back burner because
you're spending so much time and energy
on raising your kids and keeping the
chaos at bay and even finding time to
take care of yourself here and there so
that's why it's so easy to just forget
about it and be like we'll be fine you
kind of look at each other across the
room i know i've done this where it's
chaos in the house and i look at him and
i'm just like okay well i'll get to you
later we're okay right we gotta focus on
these other emergency
situations at hand and raising the kids
but over time if you put your
relationship with your partner on the
back burner it can really affect your
daily life
you feel more disconnected and it shows
up in your life and not only does it
show up in your life it shows up in your
kids lives because they can feel it they
really understand energy and vibrations
they totally can tell when something's
off especially with their parents and
how their relationship is going
so
what what's next then how do we make
sure that
taking care of our partner and taking
care of our relationship really helps us
to thrive in our daily life because when
you make it a priority to thrive with
your partner
the rest of your life will thrive as
well with your children because you'll
be happier your partner will be happier
you'll be feeling good you'll have an
easier time being calm throughout your
day with your children and your children
can feel it too so they'll be happier
too your example shows children what
love is
your example to how you treat them is
super integral i think we know that but
also how we treat our partner shows them
what love is
the way that you argue or disagree with
your partner
shows them how to argue and disagree
with other people
the way that you communicate with your
partner shows them how to communicate
with other people if you can show that
you can disagree with your partner and
have civil discussions with your partner
even when you're disagreeing or in a
little argument that shows them how to
be too you can ask yourself if you're
being civil are you being respectful
with your partner how are you responding
to them when they're doing something
that you know triggers you or upsets you
it's amazing to me how much children are
reflections they're like mirrors to us
in our own imperfections and instead of
us wanting to just stamp out their
humanity
we should instead look inward and think
about how we can evolve and grow
ourselves to reflect that example back
to them because they will do what you do
i am amazed at how much
my nine-year-old who is my oldest child
is already doing this and it's a very
helpful mirror for me to see where i can
grow and shift and change because he's
already won a super observant kid he's
so observant he'll be listening to us he
listens to everything even if he's
across the room
he's super far away you wouldn't think
he's paying attention but he's paying
attention so he's noticing and he's he's
looking and he's
being observant to how andrew and i
treat each other and how we talk to each
other especially when we're disagreeing
about something yes when things are
going well but especially when there's a
little bit of heat in the room he's
noticing
and he's already starting to act in
those ways when he's feeling heated or
upset
and
if we're modeling really good behavior
or optimal communication to our partner
then that's how our children will over
time learn how to communicate as well
but when we are acting like our lower
selves are not as
high
optimal selves to our partner
that plays out in our kids as they get
older they're going to start saying the
same things that you say to your partner
when you're mad they're going to start
talking in the same tone that you talk
to your partner when you're upset
and vice versa so i've noticed that my
kids now especially my oldest will start
talking to me
the way that andrew talks to me when
he's upset with me or we're having a
little discussion that we disagree with
and
he will talk to my husband the way that
i talk to my husband
when he's in a little thing with his dad
so that's like a huge reminder to me to
be my very best version of myself
when i'm having a disagreement with my
husband you would think it's so
disconnected right like it's not really
a huge deal um it really only matters
i'm talking to my kid but no the way
that you treat everybody and the way
that you speak about other people
um to whoever you're talking to your
kids are paying attention
um
so i think that is one of the most like
motivating factors
for how to be with my partner not only
is it helpful for my relationship with
my partner but because it reflects out
to my kids too
and some people too also
ask and consider if it's healthy to have
disagreements in front of your kids
that's like definitely a long-standing
debate on whether you should disagree or
have an argument in front of your kids
at all
or if you should
do that in front of your kids and just
be the best version of yourself that you
can be as much as you can
and i kind of land where i think it's
healthy for your kids to see you
disagree with someone
and to see how you handle that because i
think if they don't ever see their mom
or dad disagree
with anyone and see how that plays out
it's really hard for them to know how to
handle and how to
converse with people that they disagree
with because i think
healthy disagreement is
and discussion is integral and beautiful
i think it's really how i think it's
really really good to have that skill to
know how to disagree with someone and
not
start to get anxiety about it and if
they see their parents
having healthy disagreements together in
a respectful way not name-calling
not doing these low digs but instead
expressing how one is feeling
and not making it about the other
then they're gonna see how they can act
as well i'm kind of going off on a
tangent here but i really think that
that is helpful
it's not helpful for your kids to see
their parents arguing in an unhealthy
way
that is definitely has negative effects
so you kind of have to learn and know
how
for you and your partner what you can
handle and what you can do there's
there's certain times for sure where
andrew and i will say
okay let's
circle back
let's put this aside handle the day to
day right now with the kids and let's
talk about this later and i think it's
helpful even to
say in a very specific respectful way to
your partner hey i'm feeling frustrated
right now i'm feeling pretty heated i
think i need to cool down a little bit
and can we talk about this later
and that's actually like a really good
kind of code word although it's not
really a code word but it's a good way
for us to
look at each other connect and be like
hey we're we're not meeting eye to eye
on this but let's talk about it later
so it gets to a certain level i think if
you're if you're in a certain
like a lower phase something that's not
super serious it can be really helpful
for your kids to see how their parents
handle that disagreement because if they
see you overreacting and they see you
name-calling they're going to do that
too 100 and how can you blame them can
you really blame them and expect to
stamp out their humanity when you can't
even keep it together with your own
partner so yeah i think it really just
depends overall and i think that
the the stronger and more connected you
are with your partner the easier it gets
to
have respectful discourse and the more
you practice it so that you can engage
in that kind of discussion around your
kids so long as it stays peaceful and if
that's not you and you're not there then
i think it's helpful for sure to be like
let's discuss this a little bit later
all this aside how do we keep the love
alive with our partner
so that we can thrive together as a
family because like i said in the
beginning it's so easy to just put it on
the back burner and think we'll be fine
because you have so many other things
that are like current current issues to
work out with day-to-day life or just
all the things that you have to do and
get done the checklist right and then it
can be really easy to put your partner
love with my partner sex with my partner
that's on the bottom of the list right
time and quality time on my partner
that's the bottom we don't have time for
that right now we're too busy
and that can happen from time to time
but if you let it go too long like that
the relationship will suffer like i said
and it plays out in your whole family
life and your kids can feel it and it
affects them and teaches them how to
love other people and how to be
so one of the things i talk about a lot
on my instagram i probably have talked
about it on youtube before is to speak
your partner's love language
to
really tune in and to learn what makes
your partner feel the most loved for
some people that is acts of service like
taking out the trash making sure the
dishes are done before your partner gets
a chance to get to them
other types of acts of service would be
massages whether that's foot massages
back massages when you're hanging out
together
there's so many different ways to show
acts of service
i'm just speaking from my experience
because my husband's leveling which is
definitely acts of service and quality
time those are his like more dominant
and if you're not really sure what are
the love languages there's this book
called the five love languages by
gary chapman that i've read multiple
times in our relationship and have found
in an immensely helpful book
for us throughout our relationship and
so the five languages are acts of
service quality time physical touch
words of affirmation and gifts and we
all kind of generally need all of them
to some degree but there are certain
ones that we need more than others that
we feel most loved by that really speak
our language and tune in and tell us
that that person loves us
and this is not to say that we can't
love ourself without our partner's love
of course we can that's so important and
you can't just depend on your partner's
love to feel happy and well adjusted in
your life but in order to have a
wonderful symbiotic relationship with
the other it's the most helpful if we're
showing love in the way that your
partner receives it best because
my love language is
for sure words of affirmation
what you're saying to me the way that
you're saying something to me including
tone of voice are
the most important thing to me
whereas that is not important to my
husband at all
you know it's nice to hear nice things
said but they're not important to him
they don't tell him that i love him
because for him it just feels like words
he wants to see through my actions and
my quality time that i love him
so for him he's very good at keeping the
house clean and i like to keep the house
organized but for him keeping the house
clean
via taking out the trash and the compost
and the dishes
and keeping the counters clean that's
all stuff that's a very big priority to
him and most of those are kind of like
his job which i think is helpful as well
i mean this could be a whole other
tangent that
it's helpful to have tasks that you know
in your house like whose job is who that
doesn't mean that it always has to be
that way that like hey if the trash
isn't getting taken out and you're like
well that's your job i'm not gonna do it
that's like not helpful at all but if we
have a general understanding of like
okay ellen your job is the laundry and
keeping the house picked up and
organized um with the kids help of
course
and his job is more to take out the
trash and the compost and sweeping that
type of thing
but if i can surprise him by showing him
an act of service love because acts of
service is his most valuable love
language
that is like putting love deposit love
coins in their bank
and there was actually andrew and i
actually took a marriage course
a while ago it was probably was it three
years ago scott was little
and one of the things that talked about
in the course is to
is is to realize that everything that
you do every interaction you have with
your partner
is either adding love bank love coins to
their bank or taking love coins out
and in the beginning when you first
spark up a relationship
everything is just adding adding adding
you're adding all these coins to the
bank because you're just
um enamored and excited and you're
showing your best self to your partner
so everything that you're doing with
this new relationship is adding coins to
the bank and over time it can get easy
too like we said or like i said in the
beginning to just put it on the back
burner and think we're fine we're good
but when you do that
little things come up and you start to
not be your best self and by not being
your best self that you were in the
beginning showing up when you first
started your relationship
that can take coins out of your bank so
for me something that takes coins out of
the bank for me is if andrew has a tone
with me if he's speaking in a negative
tone and to him is not a big deal
because words aren't as important to him
but they're very important to me
and the way that he says something is
super important to me whereas the way i
say something to him is not super
important to him so understanding and
learning these things about each other
and acting accordingly really helps your
relationship so
over time if andrew starts having a tone
with me in half the things he says to me
or isn't affirming me in ways that he
did when we first started dating
that's taking love coins out of your
bank
and if you can learn that every
interaction you're having with your
partner how can i show up for my partner
the best that i can right because let's
just be real like parenting is
exhausting it is amazing and the best
thing that i've ever done in my life and
i'm
so thankful for my children they are the
most wonderful things that have ever
happened to me
um
it is super intense though like
every day you kind of feel like you're
putting out these little fires all day
to keep the chaos at bay
and
that's why it's so easy to just put your
relationship on the back burner with
your partner
but if you make it a priority as much as
you can and make it a priority the way
that you would make showing your
children love a priority then
everything's gonna flourish so
when your partner when you're around
your partner or when you're realizing
like for me that's when andrew gets home
from the gym in the morning he gets up
really early to go to the gym that's the
only way he's gonna be able to have time
to get to the gym so he goes to the gym
in the mornings and for me showing love
to him is having the dishes done when he
gets home
because he loves that he loves when he
can get home and just you know
make his breakfast and not really have
to do much cleaning right after he gets
home from the gym so he can sit down and
have his breakfast so having the dish is
done and then if i see the trash getting
full if i can remember to just do it
take out the trash even though that's
like his job that's showing love to him
and that really
makes him feel amazing he
loves little stuff like that
for me i appreciate when he takes out
the compost and takes out the trash but
that doesn't tell me he loves me
the way that it does for him
and the same goes for quality time for
him
so if we're not spending quality time
together after the kids go to bed
then he doesn't feel as connected to me
and he's said this before so like when
my sister's visiting in town which is
you know amazing and my husband loves
that i get to spend time with my sister
and after the kids go to bed i'm
spending all my time with her
we will have conversations together of
course but it's just not the same like
with andrew but it's not the same as
when andrew and i are alone so i have to
make sure to prioritize
spurts of time alone together even when
my sister's visiting
for him to feel connected to me
and i love quality time as well
i think we all do because we all need
all the love languages to some degree
although gifs that's not really my love
language at all
that's that one doesn't resonate with me
and much i love gifts gifts are great
but
um
well
okay sorry never mind sometimes a
certain gift can really feel like a love
like like someone's showing you love it
depends on what it is
like my friend gave me this dress that i
have loved of hers for
years
and that was such a really loving thing
to do that she gave me this dress of
hers that she owned
for my birthday one last year this
coming this past year sorry i'm on a
tangent right now
where was i i kind of lost my train of
thought
oh basically just the love languages and
by by showing your partner love in the
way that they need it most that's really
going to help deepen your connection and
help add those love coins to their bank
and what if what if though your
partner's not into the love languages
what if he's never read the book he's
not into it he or she you might be
depending on who your partner is
um he or she what if your partner is not
into it and you're like i read the book
i love it and let's let's do this love
language thing let's take the quiz and
find out what your love language is and
your partner's just not into it well you
can kind of or or maybe you have figured
out who what their love language is but
but you feel like they're not making it
a priority to show you love so it's hard
for you to want to show the other person
love because you're like hey you're not
showing me love why should i show you
love
that is something that is super common
i've totally experienced it myself
because i'm more likely to want to show
my partner love if he's showing me love
but who takes the first step who's the
first one to be like okay we're in a rut
right now we are not doing great
and we're not thriving because life is
crazy and it's hard to make our
relationship a priority
how do you decide who takes the first
step
and i think it really just comes down to
you if you are willing to take the first
step and show your partner love there's
obviously
um
external circumstances there's different
situations that are going to be
more extreme and severe than just the
typical hey i just got to show my
partner love and take out the trash and
then we're going to be all great
there's obviously more extreme
examples that are not just going to be a
little
little
change in your life that's going to make
it a lot easier and so i'm not really
speaking to those extreme circumstances
if you're having like if you're in an
abusive relationship or
something very um extreme that's
extremely unhealthy but
if you're in a relationship where you're
feeling in a rut you're not feeling the
love from your partner
what do you do first and you don't feel
like showing your partner love you kind
of have to be the first one you have to
be the first one because if you just
start showing your partner love
they will want to show you love back it
is
time and true i'm saying this wrong
hannah's going to make fun of me for it
because she makes fun of how i say
things but it is time and true again
what's that phrase
where it does that's how it works if you
show your partner love and you're the
first one in the way that you know they
love it most not by words because it's
easiest for me
i'm most naturally drawn to showing my
partner love
with words to say that i love him to
tell him how much i appreciate that he
took out the trash how much i appreciate
that he did this or that or to say how
great of a daddy is that stuff is great
and fine but that doesn't show him love
so i can say that all day but if i'm not
like
you know helping keep the house clean
cleaning the bathroom with the toilet
scrubber keeping the cleat the counters
clean like he's annoyed
because
it feels like i don't care about his
feelings about keeping the house clean
and that feels like not love to him so i
have to make it a priority to do those
things that are uncomfortable and don't
come naturally to me because actual
service doesn't really come as naturally
to me
as words as positive words
but once you start showing your partner
that they are so much more drawn and
likely to show you love back and it's
much easier for them to communicate with
you too
you may want to have like long wonderful
discussions with your partner
and they're not feeling it because
they're so tired from the day they're
exhausted they just want to lay down and
watch a show they don't want to have a
conversation right now
but if you're willing to show the other
love in the way that they love they
might want to have a conversation with
you so for us that involves like hey
i'll give you a back massage can we just
talk right now can i just like give you
show you love and massage your feet and
your back and let's just talk
or even if you just show him love him or
her
i'm speaking from my own experience
that's why i'm saying him but it could
be him or her
whoever your partner is
if you're showing your partner love
by massaging them because you know they
really love massages and not expecting
anything in return
right that's that's like even better
so you're not expecting a conversation
back but like you know your partner
wants to watch a show right now so i'm
just gonna give you a massage
while we watch a show and not expect one
back as much as i love to be like hey
you want to exchange massages right now
the kids are all asleep let's watch a
show and massage each other that's great
too but sometimes it's nice to just just
give your partner a massage if that's
what your partner likes right some
people that's not what they're into but
andrew loves massages and if you just do
that without expecting anything in
return that unconditional love is really
the key to a long-lasting love-filled
relationship so you're not expecting
anything in return that's how they feel
they're going to feel loved when you're
not trying to get anything back
so you're going to spend time and watch
a show together and massage your partner
and not expect anything back and maybe
even try it for a week straight
see what happens just see what happens
they might
surprise you and start wanting to show
you more love too in the way that you
want to feel loved and maybe your
partner doesn't really understand you
and what
you need to feel loved
and in that case don't like in the
beginning and be like hey guys
i mean you could do this
but i would say if you're feeling like
your partner isn't into wanting to do
this whole thing to make your
relationship better and they're like i
don't want to talk about this just show
the other person love and then if it's
been a while and they start realizing oh
this is pretty great like my partner is
showing me love this feels amazing
they are more likely to want to have a
conversation with you
and then you can share hey you know what
makes me feel really loved i love when
you do this
this just makes me feel so loved inside
so that's just my examples
with
the five love languages
so i said this earlier but making make
sure that you're showing
showing love to your partner is a
priority like showing your children a
love is a priority because
i don't know about you but it's easy to
be like okay get my tasks done
throughout the day
and at the bottom of the list can be
like show love to my partner spend time
with my partner have sex with my partner
because i'm like i got so many things to
do so much work to do the kids all day
you know scott wants to play a board
game with me
i got all these dishes to do and then i
like i need a five minute shower like
when am i gonna get that five minute
shower because you can barely take care
of yourself but
whatever you make a priority
will happen you will be amazed i mean a
lot of you i'm sure know but if you
don't make something a priority it's not
going to happen that's just how it is
um
okay so let's talk about sex a little
bit
making time for sex is really tricky
with a lot of kids
um even with one kid all of a sudden
it's like wait when do we have sex how
is it supposed to happen like okay when
the the kid is taking a nap if they're
young
but even then that kind of loses a lot
of the spark because you have to plan
ahead
but
that's just kind of is how it has to go
for a while planning it out if you can
make spontaneous sex happen
that's amazing but for us andrew and i
who are super orderly people
we got our schedules sometimes we have
to schedule it in to make sure it gets
it gets checked off
but not in like a okay let's just get it
done way how do we make sure that this
is what we're excited for we're looking
forward to it
um
and
and it's not something we're trying to
rush through because it's a priority and
it's a really beautiful wonderful thing
and super integral to our wonderful
relationship
um
i think the hardest part is the fact
that you're so busy with the kids
because when you're so busy it's it's
the last thing on your list sometimes
depending on you know depending on the
person it can be the last thing on your
list and
it's not the same as when you were
honeymooning or
before you had kids it's not the same
where it's just like another part of
your awesome day
when you don't have as many things to do
when you have the kids all throughout
the day at the house
it's it's just harder to make it a
priority because you can no longer just
um
have do it with uh without planning
ahead often most of the time and if you
do maybe you plan ahead and you still
somehow have kids knocking on the door
mom we had this one time where the kids
knocking on the door mom i spilled the
peanut butter it's everywhere and we're
like all right you're just gonna have to
wait
we have a little system where we set up
like you know when when the youngest kid
is napping
um the older kids can watch a show or
maybe they're at a friend's house
coordinate it in that way
and that's really helpful for us but
sometimes you know it doesn't go as
planned and there's interruptions and
it's not perfect but you can laugh
through it and it's beautiful when
you're connecting and choosing to make
connecting a priority
um
i think i think good sex is integral to
an amazing connected relationship and
it's one of those things where in the
beginning of our relationship i didn't
really realize the difference between
like sex and good sex and you're loving
it and you're so excited for it
this is this goes for male and female
not just male because there's kind of a
stigma that like just men
you know they're the ones who want it
all the time and then women were just
kind of like all right fine no you
should be having good libido and really
wanting sex and i think one of the
reasons through just talking with my
friends
one of the things that makes not wanting
to have sex happen is just the busyness
you're just so busy that it's just not
on your list you're just like i'll get
to it later so
when like i have a friend who they went
on like a little three-day vacation at
um like an airbnb a while back and they
didn't bring the kids and she's like i
wanted to have sex the whole time
because i had nothing else to do we were
just together we had no other priorities
with no other things on my list all the
stuff was done checked off my list my
kids weren't here and like we were just
so excited we just had sex multiple
times a day for three days straight and
i think that that is often something
that is within females that we're like
if we're so busy it's hard to just let
go and surrender and just let yourself
enjoy it and focus on it
but by realizing that and realizing that
you need to do what you need to do to
help you not feel so busy and to make
sex a priority for you and your partner
because it's really obviously amazing
and so important for your relationship
and this is something
well before i get there and another
thing is eating a healthy diet getting
enough sleep drinking enough water
exercising all those things that are
helpful for a healthy lifestyle like all
those things that are part of a healthy
lifestyle will create
healthy libido
and your libido and your hormones change
after having kids especially right after
giving birth especially when you're
nursing at night and you're definitely
not getting very much sleep so you
really just got to do the best you can
and take care of your body the best way
you know how by making healthy foods a
priority that's for me something that
is really important to me eating healthy
whole nutrient-dense plant foods
and those things are very
very helpful for me to have a good
libido
and i think that
one of the things that has helped me the
most
is learning about kim anami if you don't
know who kim and nami is definitely
check her out check out her podcast her
youtube channel
she has been
such a help and monumental
thing to learn about person to learn of
when it comes to having great sex and
just like being that like
the person that's like pumping you up to
be like yeah we got this this is so so
amazing and you get really inspired when
you listen to kim and ami i really
recommend listening to her
and subscribe to her email list
so that you and your partner can get
pumped up about the ways that she talks
about sex and having a wonderful
wonderful relationship with your partner
she says that sex makes everything
better it makes your life better you'll
show everything it'll show up in your
life when you're having amazing sex with
your partner
and this is not just just having sex but
amazing sex and what is it that's going
to help you have amazing sex i think
part of that is having good
communication with your partner if you
are
disconnected from your partner like we
talked about earlier and you guys are
arguing all the time and you're
nitpicking each other
that's not gonna go well when it comes
to having sex you're not gonna be as
excited and open and willing to
surrender to your partner if you're not
feeling loved by them so first start
here start with the love languages start
with showing your partner love see it
work its way to show each other love and
that will show up in your relationship
with your partner because you are going
to be excited to connect with them
and roll around in bed together or
wherever it is because you're feeling
loved by that person and vice versa
i learned about kim and ami shortly
after i gave birth to sandy my second
child a friend of mine who's no longer
on the island um she literally showed up
to my house and she looked amazing she
just looked extremely
like like i don't want to use the works
i don't think i don't know if i can use
this on the podcast but she she was
definitely having she just looked
different she looked
vibrate like vibrationally she looked
amazing she had like luscious hair she
was just glowing and i'm like
what is going on with you
what changed in you from last time i saw
you or from
the last year or two that i've known you
and she said like i'm having amazing sex
like we're we're having amazing sex and
i'm like okay like i didn't i didn't
go and coincide together that having
amazing sex could show up in your
physical appearance and in your physical
life
um and she started telling me about kim
and me and i'm like yeah my libido is
very low after just having a baby which
is super normal right after having a
baby everything in your body is going
towards producing milk to feed your baby
so
you are on and you're healing from birth
and everything is about taking care of
your baby the last thing and it's very
normal and natural for your body
in those beginning phases after having a
baby to
not be wanting to make more babies just
yet
but by learning about her
andrew and i started to dig into the
stuff she was saying and we learned some
amazing things that really upped our sex
life like amazing things that totally
inspired us and i'm not going to get
into it now but i would love to
interview her one day on the podcast
just gonna put that out there manifest
it it's gonna happen one day
um
yeah so i talked about open
communication and how that is super
integral for good sex and that even goes
through communication with
how what what kind of what kind of
experiences in sex helps you love sex
the most is your partner showing you
love through sex acts of service in sex
through each other
that is amazing something that like i
didn't think of in the beginning about
how
your sex experience and how long you are
taking the time to
open each other up and surrender will
enhance your sexual life also
something i'd like to know is that i
think it's helpful to talk to your
partner or sorry talk to your friends
about sex about their sex lives about
what's inspiring to them what helps them
to have amazing sex and just get the
conversation going maybe this isn't for
you maybe you don't have um the friend
like certain types of friends that is
willing to do this but my experience
with my friends is that
when we have a girls night you know the
dads or the partners are watching the
kids
and we get to just have an evening
together just as girls we end up talking
about sex a lot of times and it's so
inspiring because we hear each other's
experiences and then even get ideas and
input on things and
and then we all take it back to the
bedroom with our partners and i swear it
makes it make sex life better it makes
your sex life better and we'll report
back and be like wow i am so glad we had
that conversation this next time was
amazing
so i encourage you to do that if you
have the type of friends that would be
willing to have that conversation even
if you just have one friend that you're
able to just share in that conversation
some people might say that their partner
doesn't want you to share that
information
with other people even if it's like just
your girlfriends and i think it just
depends i guess on
your experience with your partner and
what you guys are comfortable with but
this is just my experience obviously
maybe it's not for everybody but
i have found it very helpful to just be
willing to talk about sex with my
friends
and it has it has definitely come in
handy in our sex life for sure
so something i want to talk about next
is what about when you disagree with
your partner on how to parent
i think
this is a huge sore spot for a lot of
relationships and
parenting and finances are some of the
top reasons that relationships struggle
so communication again is so key but
sometimes you might you might have a
partner that doesn't really love to
communicate super well or maybe you guys
just aren't vibing and communicating
very well in the moment and so that
comes back to the like working on your
relationship making your relationship
priority showing each other love being
motivated and pumped up to be like i am
going to show my partner love in the
best way that i know how and the best
way that he receives it or she receives
it
and that will like kind of bleed out
into the rest of the rest of your
relationship so that you'll be able to
have better communication and better sex
if you disagree though with how to
parent
i think that there's a few things that
come in handy because
there's a big difference between like
let's say you have massive disagreements
with how to parent that can be a really
big struggle if one of you is on this
like attachment parenting positive
parenting
road and journey while the other is more
in a
punishment um
stern not quite as
not just not the same vibrations not the
same way it can be very hard and
difficult to get to a common ground
because ultimately you want to try to
get to as much common ground as you can
so that
it in it doesn't show up into the kids
so starkly different
and
i think there's also a lot of
miscommunication and misunderstanding
with what positive parenting um really
means a lot of people think that
positive parenting is passive parenting
which it definitely is not there's a
huge difference between passive
parenting and positive parenting
positive intentional parenting where
um consequences and discipline is much
more natural as opposed to
out of the blue punishments that don't
really make sense
so
positive parenting doesn't mean that you
just let your children walk all over you
and there's no rules in the house and
they get to do whatever they want they
can talk to you however they want they
could do whatever they want no that is
not positive parenting that is passive
parenting positive parenting stems from
being respectful and treating children
the way that you would wish to be
treated talking to them in a way that
you would want to be talked to and
treating them like they're people now
not people later and i'm sure i'll be
doing more episodes on this i would love
to interview some
podcasts do some podcast interviews with
parenting experts and
parenting authors of books that i've
loved to read and i have a list of that
on my amazon shop if you want to take a
look at my favorite parenting books
right now i'm listening to
how to talk so kids will listen and
listen so kids will talk and i think
it's amazing but let's get back to
with your partner one thing that is
really helpful is to ask your partner if
they'd be willing to listen to an
audiobook or read a book
that you've recently listened to on
parenting
and maybe you have a partner that's not
into reading books as you are or not
into listening to an audiobook about
that and doesn't really want to do that
or they're not super drawn to do that
i think that
a step that is really helpful or at
least has helped me and works for us is
for me to offer to give my husband a
massage while we listen to the audiobook
together
i'll say hey there's this new audiobook
i really want to listen to would you
listen to it with me and he might not be
in the beginning he doesn't like love to
listen to audiobooks it's not his thing
and parenting books aren't ones that
he's like super drawn to but he's
willing to do it when i tell him and
express him how much how important it is
to me and how i would love to just give
you a massage for 20 minutes every night
after the kids go to bed while we listen
to this book this audiobook and that has
been really really nice we've done that
a few times and i think that's really
helpful so if that's a way for you guys
to just start to get on common ground
um i'd say go for that see if that helps
to just offer to do something for your
partner in return that will help
him or her to want to listen to an
audiobook that you find important you
can even say hey if there's another
parenting book with like a different
style that you're into like let's listen
to both of them and then engage in that
and discuss that
but um i think that it's helpful to go
the route of listening to them together
and offering to give your partner a
massage
unless your partner's not into massages
and then you'll have to go for something
else
make a commitment to not interject while
the other is parenting and disciplining
this is something that i think is super
helpful
and hard it's very hard because let's
say you come to a place where you mostly
agree how to parent
and you mostly agree on the way that you
want a parent but there's certain things
that maybe you'd handle differently
because we're different people
and in the beginning
as my kids were you know younger and
getting a little older i was not good at
this i would interject and be like hey
wait no no what are you doing no no no
that's not why are you saying that don't
say it like that why why are you doing
that no no they shouldn't have a
consequence for that what are you doing
and that made everything worse
everything so much worse not only with
my partner with andrew but also with my
kids because suddenly my kids are like
wait what like who's what's going on who
who do we have to listen to here wait so
does that mean does that mean that he's
wrong
mom doesn't think this way and it kind
of pits the kids against us or pits us
against each other and oh it was such a
bad idea should not have done that
because
when i did that that really upset not
only my partner but made it really hard
for my husband to handle
situations that he was handling and also
i just think it undermines and it's
disrespectful and that was definitely
something that i struggled with for a
while and being able to
have conversations with him on how much
that really bothered him
and just realizing how like not helpful
that was
was something that helped me to change
change that around and so now we kind of
have
a much more understanding of like hey
we're not going to be
parenting exactly the same every single
situation and i have learned a lot over
the years that it actually can be good
that you guys aren't going to be
parenting exactly the same
it's good that you're on like a similar
similar path it's common ground right
you don't really want opposite extremes
that's
that's not that's not going to be
helpful and that can cause a lot of
issues
but it's helpful to realize that like
hey maybe my partner is bringing
something else to the table that i
wouldn't have brought to the table
that i
might not have done in a certain way and
maybe i thought this wouldn't play out
well but seeing that it actually plays
out well for the way that dad's handling
it
and i think that like we bring different
energies to parenting
and we can't expect each other to be
exactly the same
if you if that's how you parent if both
you and your partner parent exactly the
same and you guys have the same
agreement on how to handle everything
then that's amazing go for that keep
doing that
but if you find yourself realizing that
like your partner's handling something
different than you would
i think it's helpful to just take a deep
breath
and realize it's okay and surrender and
let your partner handle it in a way
that's different than you would handle
it and have your partner's back and if
you really feel like a moment is
happening that you definitely don't
agree with like hey i definitely don't
think you should handle it that way
wait till after it's over wait till you
have a moment with your partner alone
without the kids around to have that
conversation and be like hey can we talk
about this
i'm not sure i think this
could have i think this could have been
handled differently what are your
thoughts on it
engage in like thoughtful discourse
where you're not like scolding your
partner or you're not like telling your
partner how it has to be or you did it
wrong
none of that i think it's much helpful
much more helpful to engage in
respectful discourse where you're saying
hey could we have possibly handled this
differently
what should we do different next time
and
if you find yourself getting into a
moment where you're getting heated or
overreacting can we have like a an
understanding or an agreement that like
the other person can step in like
because you might find your partner
you know overwhelmed and getting heated
and overreacting
and if you guys can come to an agreement
together to be like hey if i'm
overreacting how about like i you let me
step in and then you go take a breather
and vice versa if i'm getting
overwhelmed can we just like give each
other a look and you'll be like okay let
me come in and help tackle this in a
more respectful way because there's
times when
you know i have every intention to be my
most positive respectful self and to be
kind and handle it the way that i think
is optimal and then i find myself
getting more and more heated because i'm
in the moment
of chaos of all the kids having their
different things going on scouts like
spilling water everywhere you know
pouring it all out kovacs is crying at
my feet or i have him in the carrier and
he's crying and the other two are having
a sibling argument it can be very hard
to handle it the way that you have every
intention of handling it when you're
feeling tackled from all corners
so if your partner walks in and he's you
know just stepping in
to the moment hasn't been experiencing
it for a little bit
then if you have an agreement to be like
hey will you like
just tackle this for me this is what's
happening i need to step away and cool
down that's helpful for your kids to see
that you that when you feel yourself
heated that you're going to say hey i
need a couple moments to calm down and
then i'll come back because that teaches
them hey when i'm feeling upset before i
act in a way that's not healthy
or in a way that i don't mean to be that
i don't want to be maybe i can just take
a breather myself go walk away and
choose on my own to go walk away and
take a breather
so having communication with your
partner and saying this is what we're
going to do to have each other's back
and maybe we're not going to pair it
exactly the same but that's okay and
even good like that's one thing that i
had never even considered back when i
was first reading books on positive
parenting and um
and like attachment parenting and
respectful peaceful parenting i had
never read anywhere and i still haven't
really read
um what if your partner doesn't really
parent exactly like you
like maybe that's okay maybe that's good
actually at times that your partner is
gonna bring a different energy that
andrew brings a more masculine energy
that is still wonderful but handles
things in a different way that maybe i
would and maybe that's even good
sometimes but when it comes to a point
of
losing our cool if we can have an
agreement on how to handle it together
i think that creates a lot of peace in
the family where we have each other's
back we're not undermining each other
while one of us is parenting the other
and if you really disagree with
something that they've done like let's
talk about it a little later of course
this is not talking about extreme
situations of abuse or anything that is
not healthy like very like dangerous um
of course interject to your children and
this is a completely not the episode for
that and you know when it comes to abuse
i would love to discuss that with other
people in the podcast as well actually
in the future so just a little
clarification on that this does not
speak to every situation but we're
talking day to day with your partner
learning how to co-parent together in a
way that's symbiotic and peaceful and
just does really well
so i think that's like everything in my
notes that i wanted to talk about
ultimately
respect and unconditional love is like
the key to
to how to have a thriving relationship
and maybe it sounds vague like okay
respect unconditional love but how do i
do that but hopefully through
love languages showing each other love
learning how to parent together and
being respectful of each other's
differences even
can really help and go a long way and
trusting each other trust your partner
that they are doing their best too
and
they want to be spoken to in a way that
you want to be spoken to
so
working on yourself in that way because
if you work on yourself to
be the best version of yourself you're
going to have an easier time projecting
that out onto your children but also
your partner
when i'm not getting enough sleep now
i'm not getting like any kind of alone
fun time with girls like even if that if
that's like once every two weeks then i
can go have a few hours with some
friends
and just let my partner hang out with
the kids
even that helps replenish me a lot in
different in different ways so if i'm
able to take care of myself
and have basic basic necessities covered
of taking care of myself like a daily
shower and i know that there's like i've
seen memes online that are like hey a
shower is not a real break
for moms we need a real break and i i
agree i do think it's helpful and
important like i said to get some girl
time get some alone time go exercise by
yourself let your partner help take care
of you for that and if you're a single
mother maybe you're not listening to
this episode but if you are a single
parent
then obviously it's going to take
totally different adjustments and mad
props to anybody going that road in
regards to how
how much effort that is because i am
very thankful to be able to have my
husband there so that i can
let the kids hang out with him while i
go do something for myself for a couple
hours once in a while
but i do think that daily shower having
peace where i'm like hey don't let any
of the kids come in right now because
sometimes you know my younger one will
come in and take a little shower with me
and that's fine and beautiful and i love
that sometimes but sometimes i'm like
hey just like i'm gonna close the door
and just be alone in the shower just
take care of myself do some kind of like
mask or something that just like is
helpful for myself by myself for 20
minutes 30 minutes even and eating
healthy food you know all that all of
that i think is very helpful to be able
to be my most calm collected self so i'm
gonna act like my best self
so
i think that's everything for today i
hope that you found this video
or podcast of your listening helpful
and i hope you enjoyed it i love this
conversation of relationships and how to
thrive and how to parent and i
definitely want to delve into it more in
the future
with other people talking to them on the
podcast or even more by myself let me
know you liked it please leave a comment
and a review i would love that and
i will see you next time
[Music]